so donald trump suddenly appeared
yesterday for a total gong show
interview on newsmax and
it's funny it's sad it's infuriating to
some degree it's also just very strange
trump doesn't seem to be making sense he
doesn't seem
to be lucid he doesn't seem to have
clarity of mind in this interview let's
jump right into it
trump not even delaying for a second
jumping directly
into the now so tired lie
that he really won the election in 2020
and no challenge whatsoever from the
host you will notice here
being obliterated you know the democrats
are looking to
virtually demolish your second amendment
i said that was going to happen
i wanted to ask you about it you know
the election the election was
a it was a rigged stolen election
[Music]
if this would have happened to democrats
you would have had a revolution
they wouldn't have allowed it and the
supreme court
was did not have the courage to do what
they should have done because
these elections in the swing states they
didn't have anything approved
by the legislature well that's why yeah
that's why i asked you earlier
that's why i asked you earlier if the
republican party had done enough
before the election to keep some of
these things from happening when it came
to
voting laws and voting integrity which
obviously all the states now
are trying uh to do their part with that
but it's causing
a huge problem with a lot of
corporations and boycotts
well no republicans clearly did not do
enough
before the election in the sense that
they didn't suppress enough of the vote
they did not suppress enough of the vote
to win
in 2020. that's what they're now trying
to make up on lost time for
that's the genesis that's the impetus
for the georgia voter suppression bill
and more than 250 voter suppression
bills across the country in more than 40
states
listen now to trump uh answering it and
um blaming judges uh finally uh
president they did
actually they didn't they did and as you
know judges didn't want to hear cases
right you know they didn't want to be
responsible for
for this the judges didn't want to hear
the case but it's so simple
not only dead people voting not only you
know illegal immigrants and all of the
other things all of the ballot dumps all
of the things that happened at three
o'clock in the morning et cetera
forget all of that they didn't get
approval to make all of these massive
changes and you're not allowed to do it
locally or even with local
through the state judges politicians
yeah they should have never been allowed
and the supreme court
uh should be ashamed of themselves for
not being willing to take it on
no push back on anything trump says
that the supreme court should be ashamed
of itself
and the host says right trump says
illegal immigrants uh voted
and the host is silent illegal
immigrants can't vote they can't even
register to vote
trump says dead people voted dead people
didn't vote it was widely examined
all these allegations about ten thousand
dead people voting
it was investigated and there were a
bunch of buckets but basically what you
had with supposed dead people voting was
some people were accused of voting while
dead and they were alive a channel
i believe was channel 4 from the uk just
knocked on people's doors and said are
you dead and they said no i'm alive and
i voted
there were some confusions between
junior and senior
so you know like imagine david pakman jr
and david pakman senior jewish folks
don't do junior and seniors that's a bad
example imagine
like noah smith jr whose dad noah smith
senior
is dead noah smith jr goes to vote they
count it as a vote for noah smith senior
it's a clerical error
it's still only one vote they voted
under one name just the wrong name
that's just a clerical error
um there were people who were registered
to vote and they died
but they didn't vote in other words if
you
are registered to vote and you die
you're not immediately removed from the
voter rolls but you also
don't vote so there were essentially you
know
that that is just a ruse it didn't
happen and trump continues to repeat it
then this is where it gets really weird
the topic of major league baseball comes
up
major league baseball is we've been
talking about moving their all-star game
out of georgia and to colorado
over the voter suppression bill in
georgia and donald trump's answer
when he's asked should we be boycotting
baseball
trump's answer is confused it's cloudy
he seems to be saying baseball is
inappropriate
i don't even know what that means and
that he has a lot of trouble now
finding baseball games on tv which he's
not interested in watching
anyway see if you can unravel the
meaning of this answer it's
all very odd so should we boycott
baseball
well i have you know look i'm just not
very interested in baseball
for the last number of years i think
it's not
appropriate you know you look it's you
want to find the game it's on
it's on every channel and yet you can't
find anything that's the weirdest thing
it's
used to be a nice easy thing to follow
and you know what i mean by that it was
on one network and it was nice and
good and beautiful today you don't even
know what the hell you're watching so
i i would say boycott baseball why not
what is trump talking about here it used
to be
one network and it was nice and easy to
follow
now it isn't it's inappropriate so yeah
let's boycott it and i like how the host
laughs the host laughs like she shares
the experience of having trouble finding
baseball on tv
like what what are they even talking
about does anybody understand this
sounds kind of like an old man screaming
get off my lawn
uh the nba you know it's on all sorts of
weird channels
nfl games they're no longer just on
sundays and i can't
find those baseball games anymore really
strange and it actually made me wonder
as i watch this
remember trump's rant about your you
know you'll have to flush toilets 10 to
15 times
if joe biden wins maybe trump is just
confused about how toilets work
and it's less about joe biden and more
about trump's really confused because
this answer about should we boycott
baseball
and trump says i can't even i have
trouble finding it on tv
it seems very scrambled so another
strange and unusual interview from the
former president
and uh these interviews seem to be going
worse and worse for him
they also seem increasingly less
prestigious not that fox news is
particularly prestigious
but you know the prime time interviews
on fox were replaced by
middle of the day interviews on fox now
replaced by middle of the day interviews
on newsmax it's all very strange and
something doesn't sound quite right
one of our sponsors is apostrophe a
prescription skin care company for
people
ready to start taking their acne
seriously prescription acne treatment
really does work and apostrophe makes it
easy to see a board certified
dermatologist
online you'll get treated immediately
medications are delivered to your home
no waiting at the doctor or at the
pharmacy you answer some questions on
the website
take a few pictures of your skin and
your dermatologist will prepare
a personalized treatment plan tailored
to your specific needs apostrophe treats
acne but they can also help with issues
like redness wrinkles
and dark spots i went through the
questionnaire process
myself everything is super easy they
ship right to your house
it's really a great experience
apostrophe will give you
15 off your first dermatologist visit
at apostrophe.compacman the link is
underneath this video
and make sure to use the coupon code
pacman